is famine.
Mdah.
We said Abu M is his
name is Abdullah.
Very famous companion. Anyone remember
yesterday what we mentioned about when
he became Muslim?
Give it a shot.
When did he accept Islam? What era did
he accept Islam?
He he accepted Islam
in Mecca. Very good. He accepted Islam
in in the early days before the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam made
hijra. He accepted Islam when he heard
about the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
because Abu Mus
ali
is from where?
From Yemen. Ali
this is a tribe
ash right Benu a is a tribe in Yemen
very well-known tribe and it is named
after al
which is a man named
MaBud
and he is referred to as al
because he was born with hair all over
his body as soon as he came out of his
mother's womb room. They said, "Wow,
this
ash meaning the the very hairy man."
That's literally what it translates to,
the very hairy man, right? And so, ali
clan forefather because all clans are
named after the the forefather. There
would be a man for instance who has four
children and these four children come to
a particular area and then these four
men each have their own family and these
families spread in their respective
areas and generation after generation we
now have four clans and all of these
four clans are going back to this one
man who was their forefather for
instance in our example also right and
so forth. This is how clans are. This is
how it works in in the Arab Arab
clans. And so
Abu Mus who heard about the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. He heard
about him in Yemen. He came to Mecca. He
accepted Islam. And so he literally left
his homeland in Yemen and moved to
Mecca. But then things got really bad in
Mecca. And so he made hijra again to
Ethiopia.
And then things got really good in
Medina. And they made another hij to
to Medina. And they came and arrived
in Medina with the with the
caravan of Jaffur.
And they arrived just on the heels of
the battle of As they arrived so
so close to the battle of after it was
over that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam gave them all a part in the war
spoils the spoils of war from the battle
of
and that is because the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam wouldn't go
to a battle and then come directly home
the sunnah is to remain at the
battlefield for however long it takes in
the battle of bad he remained there for
days after in the conquest of Mecca.
He remained there for more than 15 days
in Tabuk. He remained there more than 18
days. And so it's not just conquering
the town or the village or the clan or
whatever it is, but it's also bringing
order to chaos. And so
it was a big fortress and it needed to
be regulated. He needed to appoint
governors now. He needed to appoint
people that would and so there's a lot
of work to do after the battle is
concluded. So they arrived in Medina
while that process was still going on.
Abu Mus Ashari was considered to be
leader material by the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. Not every
righteous man is a good leader
and not every good leader
is necessarily the most righteous man.
What does that mean? It doesn't mean
that a person can be a bad unrighteous
man and be a good leader. What is meant
is that there may be those who are more
knowledgeable
or more sincere
or more knowledge capable or more
righteous. There I is more intense.
however
there are qualities that are demanded in
leadership that aren't found in every
single person. And so there were
companions who the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam explicitly told them do
not ever take a position of leadership
don't ever be a governor you're a good
man but you would not make a good leader
right these things are not mutually
exclusive and so Abu Musa was not only a
scholar and one of the most righteous
men and most dedicated and devout
followers of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam but he was also a very good
leader So the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam sent him back to Yemen. He
governed the shores of Yemen which is
known as Yemen. He governed Zabid which
is a well-known place. He governed Aden
which is a place that bears a lot of
fruits and actually is one of the
most beautiful places in Yemen.
And so this was in the prophet's time
sai wasallam. Abu Mus Ali passed away in
the year 42
after hijra. And it's said 44 after
hijra at about 60 years old. It's said
that he passed away in Mecca. It's also
said that he passed away in alufa in
Iraq. But what we do know is that Abu
Mus Ali is one of the reciters of the
pro of the companions. The prophet
sallallah.aii
told him,
"You have been given one of the
beautiful melodous voices of the
voices of Ali D." Disam,
the prophet of Allah had such a
compelling and beautiful voice that when
he would recite the Tawra, the mountains
would start to glorify Allah
and the birds would start to sing or
melodously glorify Allah with him. the
mountains, the mountains would speak
because of the of how beautiful his
voice was and how beautiful the the
zabul was
the great prophet of Allah dam. And so
this is a great compliment from the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
telling him that you have been given one
of the one of the instruments or
one of the great voices and
melodies of
the family of Alisam. So this is Abu Mus
Ali. Anytime we go through these we want
to memorize these names. We want to
learn these names. We want to know who
these names are. Let me ask you a
question. How many of us know the names
of celebrities? Not because we research
them. Not because we look into them. Not
because we even care. Why do we know
about them? Because we are constantly
bombarded with their face and name and
story at every turn. Our culture, our
society just forces it on us. It oozes
in on us. Every time we open a a a page
on the internet to look up something or
a news or whatever, we are constantly
bombarded with these names. And so even
if we don't care, even if we try to
avoid it, even if we don't want to know
them, we end up what? Knowing who these
people are. Imagine if we cared and did
the same process with the companions
and we spent our time with them and we
looked for their names and how many
children they had and who they were and
what they did and what their stories
were and the details. We made these men
our friends because the prophet
sallall.aii
says,
"You will be gathered on the day of
judgment with those whom you love on the
day of judgment."
You will be gathered and resurrected
amongst those whom you love on the day
of resurrection. So what does that mean?
That means that if you love a people,
even if you're not physically with them,
you're with them.
And if you despise a people, even if
you're physically with them, you're not
with them. And you cannot read the
stories of the companions
and not come to love them. It is
impossible to read these men's and these
women's stories and not come to come to
love them. Abu Mus Ali tells us that the
messenger of Allah
wasallam was asked. So
[Silence]
help
menic
[Silence]
realign. foram.
for
[Silence]
Subhan Allah.
And so this man asked
there a man hypothetically
fights out of bravery.
And another fight out of pride.
And another fight out of out of
showing off another fights in order to
be seen as a fighter.
Which of these types of people is
considered to be fighting for the sake
of Allah? In the path of Allah. The
messenger of Allah sallall.aii Wasam
said, "Whoever fights
so that the with his intention being
that the word of Allah, the word of
Allah meaning the religion of Allah, the
words of Allah, the commands of Allah,
the prohibitions of Allah, the word of
Allah be the highest meaning on the
earth, then this person is the one who
is fighting for the sake of Allah." We
say the sake of Allah, but the word is
actually
A sabil is what? A path in the path of
Allah. All right. This narration has
been collected by both Muslim
and Muhammad.
which